That that was obvious from the beginning. That's why like Dean
and Parker would go get in the lines to talk to Wait, is this
Dean right here? This is Dean, isn't it? I recognize the back
of his head anywhere. This is Dean Withers, isn't it? Am I wrong?
This is Dean. I I recognize that bald spot. We already have several
farright militias. Cool. Good luck to those far-right militias.
I guarantee you half of those far-right militias are just FBI
informants. Okay. >> As though you're a fool to apply critical
thinking to this and connect the dots logically. and being bumped.
>> We're gonna get into the uh
I don't know how this is gonna go, but the guy who is there,
who's the last person Charlie Kirk debated, he released a Tik
Tok video.
Still talking about that on Twitter, by the way. That is like
a whole lot of the response on Twitter right now. Like a crazy
amount. Okay, we're going to check out the Assan Luigi Manion
clip and then we're going to go through all of the updates on
the Charlie Kirk stuff. Um, if there have been updates since,
I'll just check my research channel. I'm sure I'm sure people
will be putting um a little bit more in the uh I'm sure people
will put updates if I if I miss them at all. Anyway, we're we're
going to continue. Let's let's check this out. >> Capital
Rotunda, he was a key part of the president's re-election effort
and a very good friend of Donald Trump
>> Kyle is all in the conspiracy stuff. So is PBD. There's
a lot of people all in on the conspiracy stuff right now. It's
very funny. >> I was um Why was Luigi's shooting celebrated?
But this is tragic.
Uh couple different reasons. I think uh there are a lot of people
who have some semblance of like parasocial connection to Charlie
Kirk, which as as weird as it sounds, it's a public event.
Um, it is at a school
and Charlie Kirk is not seen as uh as >> Dude, isn't the
first answer here that like Luigi picked a target and like there
there isn't like I don't know. It feels like with Luigi the splash
against people is so much more controlled. Like he a healthcare
CEO like there's only like 12 of those people in the US or something,
right? Maybe maybe a hundred tops. But with this it's like he's
a political influencer. He's like a politically connected person.
And while there aren't as many people who are as connected as
Charlie Kirk, I think Charlie Kirk is one of the most politically
connected people in the United States. Was sorry, one of the
most politically connected people in the United States. I don't
think most people see it that way. They see it as like a that
actually could splash out to like a ton of people. Like political
violence feels like it applies to everyone in a way different
way.
Yeah. Uh sure, Major Dr. Gastley, that's another good point.
Yeah, that people knew Charlie Kirk. He was famous. The CEO,
not really at all. I think a lot of people see it as like Charlie
was killed for something that applies to them. When the healthcare
CEO dies, everybody's like, "Yeah, that's a rich who was evil.
That guy." Even Even conservatives, like a ton of conservatives
would have been like, "Yeah, like I don't want I don't want people,
but like that rich. That guy don't care about me, right? That
guy." That's so easy to write off the uh the
CEO, especially like a health insurance CEO, is like somebody
that nobody cares about. that guy, right? With Charlie Kirk,
he represents a lot of people in a totally different way. Uh,
I have seen no evidence of that. MC >> someone who was
like responsible for uh the social murder of of tens of thousands
of Americans, you know what I mean? So, those are probably some
of the reasons why.
Um, and for the record, there are a ton of people celebrating
this as well. I'm I'm not for obvious reasons. I think you I
think people here have the capacity to understand why. You know,
it's just >> Did Did people really think this is >> I'm
going to keep
>> What was weird about this? I didn't sense a single thing
that was off about that analysis. Maybe slightly incomplete,
but yeah, I I sense a single thing that was off about that. Okay.
All right. Cool. All right. Assad is bad, guys. We tried to we
tried to find a way to criticize Assan again. We up. God damn
it. I just want I just want to hate this guy. Don't you guys
just want to hate this guy? It sounds like he's saying it's okay
to celebrate Luigi.
No, he's not. He might think that. I actually wouldn't be shocked
if he thinks that. But he is saying explicitly why people don't
feel as bad. Like I don't even disagree with you that he might
think that. He might think like, "Oh, Luigi's awesome." But he's
not. That's not what he's saying here. That's not what he said
at all. Anyway, okay. We're on to the actual Charlie Kirk coverage,
guys. Let's go. We're here. We're finally here. We're finally
ready for it. Okay. So, there's a couple updates to the case.
Uh, Steven Crowder posted this morning a leak to him from the
ATF.
Now, there's some reason to doubt this, but we'll we'll read
through it first. Okay. Exclusive.
This morning, my team received an email from an officer at the
ATF. Excuse me. Jesus. Uh, got the hiccups. The email included
a screenshot from what appears to be an internal message describing
a weapon in cartridges located by an ATF and other located by
an ATF and other law enforcement near the scene of the Charlie
Kirk shooting at the Utah State Valley University or Utah Valley
State University. On September 10th, 2025, at approximately 12:24
p.m., conservative political influencer Charlie Kirk was shot
and killed at the Utah Valley University in Oram, Utah. Mr. Kirk
was speaking at the university as part of the American Comeback
Tour. Multiple Salt Lake City 1 and three agents responded immediately.
The the suspect fired one shot from an elevated position on a
rooftop in an adjacent building on the campus and surveillance
video shows the suspect jumping off and fleeing the area on foot.
ATF and other law enforcement located an older model imported
Mouser 30 odd 6 caliber boltaction rifle wrapped in a towel in
a wooded area near the campus. The location of the firearm appears
to match the suspect's route of travel. The spent cartridge was
still chambered in addition to three unspent rounds at the top
uh at the top fed magazine.
All cartridges have an engrave have engraved wording on them
expressing transgender and anti-fascist ideology. An emergency
trace has been submitted. So that's the big one here. That's
what everybody's running with. Um transgender and anti-fascist
ideology. Now, I don't know what word do you can Can somebody
tell me? You got to curve like you you got to carve like a one
word into a bullet to express transgender ideology. What's the
word? Do you guys know what the word is?
I don't even know like how you pick up a bullet. Gawk. Okay.
Yeah. You think so? Gawk.
Gawk is what they put in there. Yeah. I I don't even know, dude.
Anyway, we'll we'll keep reading. Um, an emergency trace has
been submitted uh has submitted to or
what? An emergency trace has been submitted and ATF SLC Salt
Lake City is working leads generated by the trace. The firearm
and ammunition have been taken by the FBI for DNA analysis and
fingerprint impressions. Upon completion of forensics, the firearm
will be disassembled for additional importer information. Multiple
people of interest having contacted or detained because of eyewitness
testimony and review of video footage. The primary suspect is
yet to be identified. ATF is assisting the investigation with
multiple other federal, state, and local partners. And the case
is being co-led by the FBI and Utah SBI.
So, this is uh from some actual reporting for for Ladder with
Crowder. Okay. Now, kind of important here is an update from
the New York Times that also included um this. Okay. So, let's
let's check this out cuz I I didn't see this on Twitter so much.
Okay. Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. No, I saw Porter Beller. I didn't see
this on Twitter so much, but this is an important update from
from uh the New York Times. According to the preliminary internal
report circulated inside the Bureau of Alcohol, Tobacco, Firearms,
and Explosives, federal and local officials recovered ammunition
with the rifle that appeared to raise your pay. >> One
second donation. >> Ban Ruben donated $3. BB Bird Bird
Bird. Bird's the word a bird.
The bird is the word a while a bird.
Well, the bird is the word. A well, a bird. B bird.
B bird's the word. >> Thank you so much for the $3, Reuben.
Ruben, really appreciate you. Okay. Really appreciate you. Okay.
Anyway, so so appeared to be engraved with statements expressing
transgender and anti-fascist ideology. But a senior law enforcement
official with direct knowledge of the investigation cautioned
that that report had not been verified by ATF analysts, did not
match other summaries of the evidence, and might turn out to
have been misread or misinterpreted. In fast-moving investigations,
such status reports are not made public because they often contain
a mixture of accurate and inaccurate information.
So, there's probably reason to disbelieve this to to not believe
it necessarily. I don't know what would have been on this, right?
I actually don't know what what would have been on this bullet.
I I'm trying to think of it like with the Luigi stuff. It was
like what? Deny.
It was the deny the post, right? I forget what the third word
was. The middle one. This tweet is related. Uh, I've got a lot
of other tweets, by the way, that will be coming up here, guys,
cuz this is just from the start of the day. All right. Uh,
let me open this up. This tweet will be related. Oh. Oh, no way.
FBI thought the letter TRN on the bullet was a euphemism for
trans rights.
It's worse. TRN is a common brand stamp for bullets from some
manufacturers. The blank of justice. Probably
Department of Justice. Why is this scribbled out? Probably thought
this means trans rights, bro. There's no way. There's no way
that they could think this, right? There's no shot. This is just
Hold on. This is just like It's 300,000 viewer or sorry sub like
Twitter account, but I don't know. It's so weird to me that there's
there's no way, right? Yeah. I I Come on, man. There's no way.
By the way, this is like clearly machined. You don't have to
know very much about anything to know that this is like machined
in and this wouldn't be carved by a third party. This is like
obviously machined into the metal. No, the cops didn't say this
is like somebody's analysis. Like this is like clearly machined
into the metal. It's it's so [__] stupid to to say
that this could be from like a third party. Although, hold on.
I will say though, the whole point of this is that this is a
report from like somebody who's an investigator. It's entirely
possible that somebody put this cuz they' had this put into their
head and they didn't think and they just like wrote this down,
right? But that would be why you don't release this report because
probably somebody in the ATF would have gone, "Wait, what?" and
then they would have looked and they got you [__]
[__]
right? Like that's why you get somebody to double check it before
making anything public. This was not intended to be public. And
how do I know that? Well, I know that because of another another
tweet from Steven Crowder later in the day which says that uh
just received word that my company is being subpoenaed by the
ATF. No details yet. I wonder why. I wonder why Steven Crowder
might be getting his company subpoenaed by the ATF. Yeah, confusing.
Very confusing.
Okay. One one last little to go. Someone cap off on the Crowder
conversation, okay? Cuz I I hate this guy. It's This guy's like
such a loser. Okay, but whatever. Let's check this out. This
is one of the dumbest statements I've seen so far from a major
influencer. >> 5 years ago, if someone were to say, "You
know what?" And again, I've been very clear before you came on
the show, not condoning, not supporting violence of any just
going out, not but 5 years ago, if someone said, "Man, I looks
like there's going to it looks like it's blood in the streets
time and we really have to," I would have been, "Wo, that's a
little that's a little bit sharp. That's a little radical in
not supporting and not condoning it today." When someone says,
"It seems like there's blood in the streets and it's inevitable."
I go, you know what? There are other ways, but I get it. I get
it. >> Does that seem extreme to you? doesn't it doesn't
seem irrational to me cuz >> it seems irrational just because
if you're going like well what's changed is like I kind of get
it now I get why you think that that's just you're just stepping
towards like calling for it you're just like dude you and it's
not even you're not even I feel like there's almost no meaningful
distinction between like naming other people saying other people
can have violence done to them and just saying like I kind of
get it you know I get why people want to you could say I understand
the emotion but it's bad you cannot just say
that oh well no I understand you want be violent. That saying
that in a in a vacuum is stupid. It's clearly stupid. >> Our
blood has been all over the streets for a long time. And until
someone dies, they don't give a [__] They >> This
is just the This is just the Asmin Gold statement, by the way.
>> Cuse it. >> I You know, I know you're not rooting
for it, and I'm not rooting for it either. You're saying as a
practical matter, wouldn't that be the next logical thing to
expect given how angry the right is, how victimized the right
has been? I mean, truly, the left loves to play the victim. They
love it when they're not. They invent fake ailments, disorders,
etc., and claim victimization of white privilege and white antilack.
>> I think this is just going to be like um I I don't think
this actually possibly turns into a civil war, but I could see
this turning into like um sort of like desperate terrorism like
like basically like the um the FLQ in Canada or or like the uh
what is it? The IRA like the Yeah. Like I could see it turning
into like terrorism where people take shots at like political
people. I I could see it I can't see it going into full-blown
civil war personally.
Um cuz I don't think really even Charlie Kirk was probably one
of the biggest people who could be targeted. I just don't think
people care enough to be honest. We already have several farright
militias. Cool. Good luck to those far-right militias. I guarantee
you half of those far-right militias are just FBI informants.
Okay. Those guys those guys stand no chance of getting [__]
done. Going ban for b. Yeah, that's what I would see it being
Porter Bellar is people doing like decentralized terrorism like
Hassan said, right? Like it won't be anything organized. I don't
think you have enough privacy in the United States to get organized
terrorism off the ground. I just don't believe it. Uh the your
your government has every right to spy on you as much as they
want. Okay? Well, not technically, but they do spy on you as
much as they want. All right? You guys will never have organized
terrorism that gets that takes off. It just won't happen. Although
the scary thing would be if Trump's in power, okay, they might
go, you know, we're not going to watch the right-wingers, but
the left's not going to get any organized terrorism off the ground.
I could see that happening. You know what I'm saying? I can see
that happening 100%. Which is pretty terrifying, right? With
Cash Patel at the head of the FBI,
but there won't be real organized terrorism that's perpetual.
Um,
yeah. Yeah, evil Johnny Bravo. It's like, yeah, I I agree with
you entirely that like it used to be that you could have like
an uprising in one part of the country and it would take like
weeks or days to do something as the government and it's like
no, the government can like dispatch Apache helicopters and reach
any point in the country in like 5 minutes. Anyway,
well, let's keep listening here for a quick >> etc. and
claim victimization of white >> dude. That's that's just
because just to be clear, the CHAZ chop stuff only exists because
the federal government doesn't have the ability to go into those
cities. They don't have the authority to do that, right? But
if there's like a state of emergency or something, they could.
Uh if there's like actual terrorism, there's a reason to believe
the federal government has to go there. They can immediately
invoke what is it? The insurrection act or something. They there's
like a bunch of different things they could evoke and they can
just go in. But like they didn't um they didn't do it with Chaz
or Chop because like yeah, they just figured that was going to
play itself out. white privilege and white antilack racism all
the time >> when it doesn't exist. We actually are being
victimized. There's no other word for what happened to Charlie
Kirk
>> They he was hunted and they victimized his beautiful
wife and their beautiful children and all of us who loved him
and his message. That that's actual victimization. A word I hate,
but it happens to apply here. But they don't see it. You know,
>> why would you hate the word
That doesn't make any sense either. Just like like you don't
listen to these people for a long time and you just realize that
they're actually just morons the entire time. I don't like the
word victimization
cuz it's overused. So just use it appropriately and don't say
you hate it. Really have to say beautiful wife every time. Do
you Wait, hold on, Ozel. Yes, you do. Just like Teto when he
talked about that Ukrainian girl who got stabbed. Okay. She was
She was so beautiful. She was so clothed. She was so covered
up. Okay. I don't I Yeah, there's some weird
thing going on with a bunch of different commentators that I'm
I'm very put off by. I don't know how to talk about it. All right.
Do you understand how their viewership thinks? No, it's sorry.
Yeah, sure. You could say that these people aren't stupid. They're
actually just trying to like weaponize their audiences and gain
people. This is why, by the way, you need some control for the
people who are going to amplify this stuff. If your only goal
is to like rabble rouse, you need a way to like knock monetization
off of these people or find these people. It's the exact same
concept, by the way, as uh what I talked about with with like
protests that turn violent where it's like, "Oh, that protest
turn violent. We need to break the arm of everybody there as
they leave, right?" Like, you need to pay a price for amplifying
or causing violence. And it can't be like your life. I don't
think that's appropriate, but it needs to be you need to have
some pain. There needs to be some friction there. If you have
totally frictionless like uh calls to violence, totally frictionless
calls to like like destroy or not care about America, then that's
that's the problem to me, right? Cuz that kind of like amplifying
that kind of discontent is so effective in terms of media.
You you can't just let it go with like nothing else happening.
Nope, not deplatforming. Nope. Um like basically I think you
leave everybody on the platform. You just say, "Okay, you're
you're not getting paid for the next week. Whatever your ad revenue
is for the next week, you lose it." I don't think this is deplatforming.
I think you just take their money away, right? So, we're not
doing it long term. We're not doing it for a long time, but you're
actually just losing you're you're going to lose your ad revenue
for a week. Or if you've done this like four times, you're going
to lose it for a month. I think that's incredibly appropriate
right now. I think a bunch of these people should be losing their
ad revenue for sure. Uh TRN denotes where it was made. In this
case, it was a city in Italy, I believe. Oh, thanks. Thanks,
L. But repeat offenders. Yeah, with repeat offenders, you eventually
push into that, right? The issue is I don't know how you do that
in a nonpartisan way. it with every every single platform is
going to handle it in a partisan way. And I have no idea how
to fix that. I just don't know if there is a way to fix it. I
thought that was deplatforming. No, deplatforming is banning
people, not letting their voice get out. Right. I'm demonetized
on Twitter and I don't even know what for and they just told
me I'll never get it back and they said there's no appeal process.
I've been demonetized on Twitter since like a month after my
Twitter was made and they just said you'll never ever get it
back. Crazy. But I'm not deplatformed from Twitter. I can still
tweet. None of my like with anyway. Okay, we're getting back
to more stuff from the actual shooting.
Okay, earlier this morning, we get uh like a shot from basically
where the the the shot was fired from here. We get these dots
that go and correspond to where this stuff is on the ground.
So, this is where the shot came from. All right. Oh, there was
this right here that I thought was interesting. They There's
like a lot of different trans people they've been trying to blame
for all of this. Okay. But the these are the pictures the FBI
released of the person. I think it was the FBI released these
pictures of the person. Yeah, there's the Soundcloud transperson
which is I think people's like top top one they're looking at
right now. Won't they just do Patreon/crypto instead? Yeah, but
it's way it's way less good than the actual um like advertising
and stuff that you get on the platforms. Okay.
Also saw Taylor Hansen tweet this out. This is drone footage
from overhead of where the shooting took place. So we're seeing
down here is where the where Charlie Kirk was. I didn't think
it was up here. I thought it was over further left. Okay, I keep
looking. the shooter location up here. Dude, this drone footage
is like video the shoot uh the shooter on the roof from there.
Okay.
Are they going to show They're not going to show like the angle,
dude. What? Why did you fly a drone out here and you don't go
over to like where you say the shooter would have been and show
the angle?
What is the point? Why would you not like fly over to where you
say the shooter was and show the angle? Oh, they're showing the
the stairs and stuff though. Interesting.
Should have ran back. I wonder if these are the only ladders
down.
Right. I wonder if they had to go down these ladders. Go down
these ladders cuz I don't think you would have seen them going
down these ladders on front. They must have gone over here, right?
Gone off the building somehow.
How the [__] did no one catch a person jumping down
from all this stuff? There are videos of the person running.
Like we watch videos of the person running away. And there are
a few more videos that were picked up today. So, let me see here.
Drone footage. This is another thing. Apparently, the FBI has
announced just a little while ago, this is about 3 hours ago,
that they found the name of the person. Okay. Believe they have
identified the name of the per of a person of interest in yesterday's
assassination of Charlie Kirk. Though no suspect is in custody
and no arrest warrant has yet been issued according to two US
officials and a law enforcement source that spoke with CBS News.
Law enforcement now states they've not identified the person
of interest in the shooting of Charlie Kirk denying a report
earlier today from CBS. So this is them walking to the shooting
in another video which we also have. Okay,
there's this guy right here. It looks like there might be higher
quality. This was TMZ found this footage. So, you can see them
walking. They seem to be walking with a limp. No, no, no. They
They're walking with a limp on the way there.
They literally are walking with a limp on the way to do the shooting.
The rifle is in their back that backpack. They might have assembled
it on the roof so that they wouldn't get caught, right? Walking
around with a rifle. He stood the gun in his pants apparently.
That could be the thing that he's like keeping one of his legs
stiff, but neither of his legs I guess his right leg staying
pretty stiff, right? That's why it appears he's like you could
say that substance. I think that's possible, but I don't know
that that's for sure. They stabilize here cuz you see the person
run by. Saw them run by before, right? This is them going by
in the other direction. Doing crime in 2025 is impossible with
all these door cams. Well,
seems like they got away cuz Oh, here we go. Cuz the thing you
got to remember, did I go back far enough? There we go. The thing
you got to remember is it takes them so long to track all these
things down that >> like you have so much time to get away.
>> $3. That is quite the usual suspect's limp that guy
has. >> Okay, not for long. I mean, dude, if this guy if
this guy hit his face better,
there's a decent chance they get away. How fast did they catch
Luigi? They c they caught Luigi because Luigi like showed his
full face.
That's why they caught Luigi.
You don't show your face anywhere in the same city. Your face
has to be hidden the entire time. If you show your face anywhere,
your Dude, the Rabbi Schmooy thing is crazy. The Rabbi Schmooie
thing was nuts. I don't know if you guys saw Rabbi Schmooie like
crowdfunding off of Charlie Kirk's assassination for his own
Pretty nuts. Okay. Pretty goofy. Not a fan. Not a fan at all.
All right. Hold on. What are we What are we looking at next,
guys? We got a couple more reactions today. Okay. What do we
want to start with? Dave Portoi. Did I Oh, what?
Get the out of here. I better have my Dave Portoy video right
at the start of this. I'm gonna be annoyed. This guy delete his
Dave Portoy thing and then he didn't even put it back. Are you
dude? What? Dave Portoy was like blaming this on. Not blaming,
but um Hold on.
Hold on. I like this. Okay. >> Did Dave Portoy just blame
President Trump for Charlie Kirk's death?
Definitely has politics
definitely has a
huge part in it. Trump and and when I say Trump has a huge part
in it, I don't necessarily mean he's to blame for it, but he's
so divisive without really even just his face is like divisive.
like he just people hate him so much and the left and the right
the rhetoric especially to me the left is insane and it just
boils boils boils boils and this happened when Trump they they
threatened when when his assassination attempt there's like a
threehour period of like let's tone down the rhetoric and then
they're right back to it all politics so
I mean that's not even like a that's not even a crazy take to
be honest with you and he's definitely not blaming Trump at All
but uh
Jose was Dave posts a longer clip. This is why I despise politics
in both extremes. This terrible bot should be ashamed. Here's
the full clip. Go [__] yourself using my name for
clicks, you loser. If anybody disagrees with what I said, you
have cement in your brain. Okay, >> social media.
>> These are these are the the wise men's council. I don't
even know who this is, but I do know Dave Porto is like and I
do know Ryan Whitney is also categorically.
So glad I can see all three of these. Sorry, both of these guys
on the screen talking >> plays a gigantic part
in in it amplifies everything and every Yahoo has a voice and
when things like yesterday happened, you see it all. I mean,
how about the MSNBC
and that guy got fired to publicly say maybe got >> Dave
Portoy wanted Gre Thumbberg to get hit by a missile, right? Dave
Porto has gotten a little crazy with his takes, okay, the whole
Israel Palestine thing. Little wild. shot by one of his own fans
who like was in the Old West like shooting his gun in the air
like celebrating and then to be like he deserved it because he
spews hate which by the way a lot of people agree with what he
said what he says and he says his things and lets people who
disagree with him like you were saying come up and debate him.
So yeah,
crazy. I mean, but my thing is like, and I get what Wit saying
like he has kids. I feel terrible and I see people like tweeting
out, "Hug your kids. Do all but like I feel like we do this every
time there's a mass shooting or some it's not going to get it's
just not going to get any better." >> And that's the most
terrifying part of >> It's just gone. Like the toothpaste
is out and it's not it's just it's over. >> So it's like
what? Yeah. What could ever change it? I I I don't think there's
anything which is the saddest part. And then the other part is
like I don't even know where it was where the politicians like
they're screaming and yelling no no moment of silence. It's just
like >> oh in the house yesterday >> that was that
was on the house. >> Like I I don't even get that. Like
you can't just be like yeah let's say a quick prayer. I Yeah.
It's just
>> I think the problem is I think it's just the total disconnect
from politics of most of these people. Like they just don't know
what what these people advocated for, what they like what their
positions are. Like dude, this guy was pretty openly racist like
in a in a not so coded way a lot of the time. Like he was he
was the guy who was totally willing to double down on that stuff.
I understand why a lot of a lot of people in the House of Congress
or sorry the House of Representatives might not have wanted to
have a moment of silence for him. Uh they did the moment of silence.
Oh, they did the moment of silence. It was only for Boowbert's
prayer afterwards. Interesting. >> Definitely has a huge
part in it. Trump and and when I say Trump has a huge part in
it, I don't necessarily mean he's to blame for it, but he's so
divisive without really even just his face is like divisive like
he just people hate him so much and the left and the right the
rhetoric especially to me the left is insane and it just boils
boils boils boils and this happened when Trump they they threatened
when when his assassination attempt there's like a threehour
period of like let's tone down the rhetoric And then they're
right back to it. >> Yeah. That's why I think it's yesterday
when people are the people on the extreme left are like, "Oh,
I'm so sorry." It's like, "Well, I I don't think you are like
I you know, I just don't like I don't." So why why pretend? Just
tell the truth. I think Charlie Kirk would would rather have
you tell the truth. If you sit there and you say call people
and now Mick is, but if you sit there and call people over and
over, it's not true and over and say that they're uh threatening
democracy
and they're fascists over and over and over and over. You can't
then be like
this is the only thing I I cannot like uh stomach or or reconcile.
There has to be absolute absolute absolute freedom of speech
describing other people's political positions. Now, if you want
to say, "Oh, don't call him fascist. Say what his fascist policies
are." I could maybe agree with that. But holy,
when these guys just sit here and go, you shouldn't be able to
say he's a fascist. You shouldn't be able to say he's threatening
democracy. It's like, he is attempting to run for a third term
pretty openly. Pretty out in the open. What do you mean? It's
>> what happened? Like that's you they that goes together
because >> weren't you saying people
or you truly think you're a fascist in your head you're like
I did good for society. >> Uh yeah okay then you have to
accept the the correlary of that right which is okay you can't
call these people communists anymore. You can't do that. That's
not allowed. If we want to get rid of you know hyperbolic rhetoric
entirely then you have to get rid of it both ways. Can't just
do it one way. Anyway, that was the uh the Dave Portoy stuff.
Okay, Dave Portoy actually checked in making some statements.
Has some stuff going on. Oh, where do we go from here? Okay,
I've got a couple different things. I do want to cover the uh
the Warren Smith.
Okay, >> nobody nobody should be shot for their >> Now,
I have no idea what this is going to be. 8 minute Warren Smith
video. Okay, we're going to watch Warren and then we're going
to get into the uh
I don't know how this is going to go, but the guy who is there,
who's the last person Charlie Kirk debated, he released a Tik
Tok video. He's a part of UN America as far as I can tell. So,
we might go through some of the UN America stuff, their responses
to it. I think Z dropped a response and then there's another
guy who uh who posted about it. Okay. Uh, kind of up. Kind of
up. All right, we'll we'll be checking it out. All right, I'm
going to hit play on this. I'll be right back. >> Nobody
Nobody should be short for their opinions. Even though >> I
keep saying now I can say if he was. >> How I feel about
the death of Charlie Kirk is less important than the game that's
now going to begin. >> Why has his apparent murder prompted
such an extraordinary outpouring?
>> As though there's any chance this wasn't he wasn't murdered.
Wait a minute. Nobody should ever be overviews or words. It's
just completely >> Do I sound I I I mean, obviously I agree
with every single syllable of what you've said, but do we not
do we not need to be sure that he was before we say that? >> What
other possible motivation logically is there? >> I suspect
it wasn't from, you know, an angry ex or something like that.
>> It was motivated by who Charlie Kirk was, what he stood
for, what he said, his ideas. I may be wrong. Time will tell
regarding his death. I'll share my thoughts on the end. But I
think this is what he would want to get straight into >> Why
Why is there this already frenzied attempt
to pretend
that they know what happened here? >> Because we have two
eyes and we can see you know I agreed with certain things he
said other things well family values um you know promoting being
you know bringing up children in a safe and stable stable environment.
Um, >> that's fairly I don't think anybody's in favor of
unstable environments, are
>> Okay, I'm back. What is Warren doing? Warren's like
he absolutely was for his political views. I think that I think
so. If I'm wrong, time will tell. Okay, you just said the same
thing. He literally just said the same thing as them. Really
cares more about not how we got here. No, it's about what Charlie
Kirk said about Taylor Swift and her husband. I think he said,
did he say that Taylor Swift should submit to her husband at
some point? >> Yeah, that's one of the things he said which
I don't agree with. >> And notice that he doesn't actually
read the quotes. >> A couple of things that have already
been pointed out include his observations, his recorded observations
that uh that death is the price you pay for the gun laws that
he very enthusiastically approved of. I >> all he was saying
is that there's no perfect system. There will be people that
abuse it just like freedom of speech. If we have freedom of speech,
there will always be consequences. There's no perfect system.
Winston Churchill, democracy is the worst form of government
except for all the others. There's no perfect system. That's
it. That's all he was saying. >> Let me read you a few
texts just to highlight what >> I actually don't think
that's all he was saying at all, but >> I'm doing today
>> and listen to what the people writing in are saying.
>> Um, this the first is from Samuel. You literally called
a racist and intentionally divisive person courageous. You can't
make this up, right, Samuel? People are openly applauding his
death. >> Um, Dez writes, "I love you, James, but if you
actually knew about Kirk or were a black, Latino, or gay American
afraid to walk the streets, you'd be a lot less liberal about
his death." >> And then the last person does point out
the game that he's playing. >> Uh, and Angela writes, um,
what you're doing is really wrong in my opinion. If you were
shot dead, presumably for your political views, would you want
a right-wing American radio talk show host to ask Americans to
ring in with their opinions of your views and paraphrase what
you have said? It is just wrong. Stop it. So, I mean, all three
of those people listening to exactly the same radio program and
arriving at those >> those are totally different. What
is What is the point of this? Also, somebody just said like he
was being way too kind to Charlie Kirk. Isn't Warren saying like
claiming Charlie Kirk's murder wasn't political? I mean, [__]
Like, I think everybody's at like 98% of political. Like the
other possibility there is that somebody who is like a total
schizophrenic like has been the case many times right who doesn't
have any consistent political ideology who just knows a famous
person is coming and this is where they can make their mark >> those
incredibly contradictory >> oh god
Steven A Smith my thoughts on char on the death of Charlie Kirk
>> conclusions a couple of messages early on this hour
suggesting that I am somehow pleased about this
terrible
that's projection Mate, I won't read your messages out. I just
want you to reflect upon what you've said and why you've said
it. What what you are acknowledging there is that if somebody
from the other side of the political divide and I'm still not
entirely clear where Charlie Kirk sat for which I I do apologize.
I should probably know >> yet you just characterized his
statements that you have written down in your notebook. >> But
what you're saying when you suggest that you >> wait
when you say didn't he say this and everybody's like yeah he
did say that. What do you mean characterize? Where's the characterization?
You know, sorry. If you feel like reading off his statement about
how Taylor Swift needs to submit to her husband is like a characterization,
I Why did he say that?
>> You can hear glee in my voice or anything other than
sadness at the and confusion at the character. What you're doing
is projecting how you would feel if somebody you disagree with
politically were to be >> This exposes your game. But given
that he lived and tragically died very much in public debate
in the public space in in in immersed in public discourse, it
would be ridiculous and absurd not to explore what his contributions
to public discourse were. >> Are you going to point out
any of the positives? Why are you only pointing out things that
you don't like if you're really just trying to explore his
And if you don't like the evidence of what his contributions
to public discourse were, that's that's that's
for you to deal with. That's for you to work through. He immediately
established the frame at the very beginning as though Charlie
Kirk really I don't understand why anyone really knew about him
cuz all I saw of him online. The only time I saw him online was
him getting owned by >> I have been surprised by the scale
of the response. I knew the name. I have seen some clips. I wouldn't
necessarily have been able to say that is Charlie Kirk. I would
have said that is the guy who I have seen getting kind of owned
by young students.
>> what? Where?
Hold on, Cringle. I don't think I don't think Cherry likes Warren
Smith at all. I don't I don't think that's accurate. I think
a lot of people don't like Warren Smith. I just like playing
him because it's like painful every time.
It's like it's it's just funny to me. Okay, dude. This is This
is amazing. I saw him get owned by college students. Really?
>> I have seen getting kind of owned by young students.
>> Seriously,
that's one hell of a frame.
>> Some of the pronouncements that this chap has made in
the past, particularly um with reference to uh >> uh also
guys, if you're watching on Twitch, I'm going over to kick. So,
we'll see you guys in a little bit. Okay? Heading over to kick
only. Love you guys. Thank you for being here. See you in a bit.
Bye. Hold on. Hold on. Give them a second to switch over from
Twitch to kick.
All right, we can do >> I I would suggest off the top of
my head and um and and Black Women's
>> he says off the top of his head as he looks down and
reads it off the script that was prepared to do this exact plan.
Why don't you read the actual quotes? Why don't we actually look
at it in
>> I don't even know. >> What is the context behind
Charlie Kirk talking about black women's intelligence? I actually
don't know
Oh, I I I can't even begin to speculate. Well, I am speculating
on I can't even begin to reach conclusions.
>> The problem is really what Charlie Kirk represented,
which is the same thing that probably motivated that shooter.
We can just
It doesn't take a leap. This morning, Steven Crowder received
a tip from a source. All cartridges have engraved wording on
them expressing transgender
and anti-fascist ideology. >> That has since been confirmed.
So this whole guy >> that wait that has since been confirmed
by who? By who? Warren. Wait, who? I I was under the impression
it was explicitly not confirmed.
>> Guy's narrative just blew up. >> Hold on. I don't
see anybody pointing out that that's clearly not true, but >> What's
the word? Why has this apparent assassination
stopped the traffic on this side of the Atlantic and beyond?
>> They disguise it as though they are being responsible
by not drawing any
>> I don't I don't know that that is the thing we should
be focusing on, but it's the thing that has boiled my brain the
most this morning as someone who commentates upon current affairs
for a living. as though you're a fool to apply critical thinking
to this and connect the dots logically. >> I'm being bombarded
from all >> Wait, but this guy probably thinks there's
like a 95% chance it was a political assassination. Maybe even
higher. He's just like, "Oh, it's probably responsible to say
apparent political assassination instead of like or apparent
assassination instead of like just or instead of assassination
like apparent that seems fine." sides by people who haven't got
a Scooby-Doo, what happened or who did it or why,
>> expressing absolute certainty of what this represents
and how it's proof of some enormous broad truth. >> So,
let me get this straight. So, it's impossible to deduce anything
about what motivated this act. So, you're going to spend the
next 20 minutes pointing out how bad Charlie Kirk was. >> Well,
we don't even know whether it's political. I want to keep stressing
this point, but of course >> and then they pivot immediately
back to and this is awful and compassion. >> This is a
31-year-old man with two little children and if that doesn't
touch you at all then you really need to give your head a wobble
knows perfectly well that this was a political assassination
and right here he slipped. >> Bro, does this guy just hate
the the British dude or something? Why the [__] why
the is this happening? Can someone explain? I don't understand.
Like the guy, the British guy has like a perfectly reasonable
take on everything here. Like totally reasonable, the most reasonable
take.
Also, I feel like I have the take that I I feel like Charlie
Kirk was a big deal. He was incredibly well-connected, but he
was sort of under the radar um to a lot of people who weren't
like tapped into American politics. Under the radar is the wrong
expression. Um
unless you were pretty aware of right-wing politics. You knew
the name Charlie Kirk and you knew he was a goof, but a lot of
people didn't understand the level and degree of influence he
had over the administration over like really high high up media
figures and stuff. They didn't really know much about him. So,
I totally understand why a lot of people would go, "Yeah, I don't
understand why people think this is a big deal." And I I also
don't get I think they're lionizing him a lot um in terms of
what his like
I think media is lionizing him a lot because he is the guy who
got
which, you know, for better or worse, that's what's happening.
flips up. It admits it. >> Indeed, even try and turn it
into some opportunity to attack the left, some of whom, the idiots,
will not be offering unequivocal condemnation and uh and sympathy
for an act of political violence, for a political assassination.
There's a deep something very disturbing about the the fact that
he died on a college campus where these kind of conversations
and thinking should be occurring. What we need next is for people
without followings that are not public figures to step up and
continue on. For the secret scholars to no longer be secret >> to
have the conversations.
If everyday people step up, they can't stop that. And in that
way, >> Charlie Kirk will live on. >> Oh my god.
Love the pie. We still don't know why he was. Just so you know,
the the ATF has not confirmed that writing being on the bullets.
That hasn't been confirmed. Nobody's confirmed. In fact, I believe
people have come out and said like it's kind of unlikely that
that would be true. Dude, I I have to hear about how this is
a turning point for America or anyone. One more time. Here are
the new photos, guys. New photos of the the person who been that's
have been released. Looks like a an eagle. I can't really see
what else is going on there. It looks like an eagle and an American
flag. Okay,
this guy was dressed to blend. I can't see too closely. I wouldn't
be shocked if they were hiding the rifle in their clothes and
[__] right? We know the shirt source. Some veterans
charity. No way. Could have been bought secondhand, though. Ooh,
that's a little crazy. 40 minutes for a new for a new thing.
Okay. All right. Cool, cool, cool, cool, cool, cool, cool. All
right.
Uh, where are we going next? I think I still have more stuff
here, don't I? Do I not? Oh, I do. I actually do. Okay, one more
one more quick reaction and then we're gonna go on to the PB
related stuff with
>> Mr. PBD on Fox News with Jesse Waters of all people.
Okay. Patrick Bet David warns that if a major left-wing influencer
is taken out in the coming days, it won't be by accident. He
says it would prove that an outside country is actively trying
to push America into a civil war.
Dude, >> if if an event like this happens to somebody on
the opposing side the next 48 hours, the next week, think about
the equivalent of Charlie Kirk on the other side. If an event
like this has happens on the opposing side, you have to know
a country on the outside wants to see a civil war in America,
that that concerns me a lot. If if an event like this happen
I just I love the just fully embracing like the conspiratorial
thing here, right? I love it. There's also a second Jord's video.
What's the second Jordy's video? Was it because his first video
is like kind of pointless? >> Well, obviously after the
Kirk assassination, which I've got to say still has rattled me
quite deeply.
That was sick. I think it was mostly just the fact that you saw
the footage from every single angle. And unlike the JFK assassination,
which happened so long ago, it's not grainy.
It's It's there for everyone to see. That was
unsettling on both a personal level and a social one because
it really does say something about the American psyche. I think
I I unfortunately unfortunately I just um I want Friendly Jordies
to be funny. I don't want his like actual philosophy.
Sorry. I It's like what it is what it is. It's just like not
not really how I feel about it. Okay. Yeah. Yeah. I just I I
would want him to be funny or be doing like a bit of some kind
and just like him providing his like sober takes and this is
just whatever. Whatever, man. Okay, let me pull the Z stuff up
here. Z to the hills. The Z response. Z to the hill. Okay, so
this is where we're I gave away that I liked it.
Huh. Who's this guy? Sorry. Anyway, get ready for a shock. No,
there's not going to be any side profile. I don't think so. I
you get the sense of depth here though. There's like there's
a sense of depth here that's going on. It's like it's like there's
a green screen. You could just see her face. She's wearing like
a from the from the chin down she's wearing like a green, you
know, zentai suit and there's a green screen and then her body
is like set back and her head is like forward, right? I think
so. >> I've been thinking a lot about what I want to say
in this video and I'm just going to go ahead and say it. If this
is the first time you're seeing me, my name is Z. I run an organization
called National Ground Game and the America Tour, which is the
counter to Charlie Kirk's Turning Point USA.
And I just want to start by saying that, >> dude, I was
uh I was just laughing today. A bunch of people are like there's
a whole bunch of people who are convinced that uh me and Quan
are endeavoring explicitly to make people think that like Z and
Destiny are responsible for Charlie Kirk getting shot. And it's
like I was just laughing at how weird it was to see the guy get
shot and go, "We're totally, dude. We're totally to do that on
a public live stream, but there's a whole bunch of people on
Twitter who are like explicitly thinking that who like can't
see that it's like just funny. It's very It's very funny to me
the the like I'm getting tagged by DJs who just very mad.
>> I'm so disgusted from both sides of the aisle. the reaction
that we've gotten not just towards me but towards my entire team
the past 24 hours. I could hardly go online yesterday. The person
that was debating Charlie at the event
when he was shot um was actually part of the America Tour team
and had to witness that which was obviously extremely
I don't know what the differentiation is timelinewise there.
Am I the only one? I I would like to know cuz the guy was debating
but the video of him debating with Charlie Kirk about like transgender
shootings
that's like totally disconnected from the later video of the
guy getting shot. So yeah, I don't I don't necessarily know.
A lot of people on our team
saw footage um that we will never unsee and that's very traumatic
and coming online and seeing the reaction from people and having
gone through that and then getting death threats angers me to
a whole new level to a whole new level again from both sides
of the aisle. And I just want to start by saying that two weeks
ago I was on CNN and I was >> I like I don't know if she
maybe just didn't see maybe she just didn't see the tweets but
it was like hey it's kind of ghoulish to go and like talk about
yourself before being like saying about how awful it is with
Charlie and then she just did it a second time. But I I have
a feeling so she did put up the response that had the condolences
for Charlie Kirk. I think I retweeted the uh America response
that had the condolences for Charlie Kirk. But I don't understand
why she would do it again here. Like just start your video if
you're doing a video on this. Just be like, "Oh yeah, first of
all, here you go." That it's just so obvious, right? >> Is
talking about Charlie Kirk and about what he's built at Turning
Point USA.
And I said what I said then and I will continue to say that what
Charlie built at Turning Point USA was incredibly impressive.
So impressive that I wanted to replicate it on the Democratic
side. I still do. and he's the only person that I know um that
has been able to have the creators
married with the ground game in a way that has won elections.
And as you all know, I very much disagree with Charlie Kirk
but what I respected about Charlie is his willingness to debate
and to bring that debate to college campuses across the country
even though we disagreed.
And um
Charlie, I was actually we had a scheduled debate a week from
Sunday. I was very excited
um to be able to debate Charlie face to face and to meet him.
And of course now that won't happen. And if you are >> so
again again it's just like almost entirely focused on dude I
it's honestly um it's just off-putting and and like it's I don't
even know if it's like wrong. It's just like offputting to me.
That's that's all >> the type of person that is laughing
at this situation and that thinks that this traumatic event is
funny
um or that he deserved it, then please just unfollow me now.
And if you're the type of person that was laughing at Dean Withers
crying, even though you all know I have a strained relationship
with both him and Parker, if you were in Parker's comment section
making fun of him, um, you can also unfollow me cuz I think that
you're a horrific human being. And I think you need to be in
a mental
>> Dude, some people listen, that's the way some people
cope with tragedy, by the way. That's how some people cope with
tragedy. That's it. So I just I don't have a lot to say right
now other than
the entire purpose of the UN America tour
is to bring debate
to college
>> Uh I thought it was like to expose Charlie Kirk. I thought
it was actually pretty focused on Charlie Kirk. I don't know
that it was just about bringing debate. I don't I think that's
what it was after you like couldn't talk to him, >> right?
I think I think that was a focus shift, but maybe I'm wrong.
and to register voters
and to have a dialogue with people that we disagree. >> If
that if your if your only goal was to bring debate to college
campuses, why did you plan your tour around where Charlie Kirk
was going to be >> agree with in order to bring people
to our side and to win elections and
>> uh we're just we're about bringing debate to college
campuses. Okay.
All right. We'll we'll see. Maybe it's maybe it's changed where
it started. The America Tour is created largely through the efforts
of National Ground Game NG, a grassroots powered pack that deploys
organizers in all 50 states. The pack came to be came to be in
response to the results of the 2024 election. What drove the
votes and caused the disconnect with a focus on deep canvasing.
NG strikes blah blah blah blah blah. Now the America tour is
coming to life. Members of the tour will take the far right and
their conservative agenda headon. A team of influencers and creators
will pave the way for this tour across the nation. It's time
to un America. Wait, where's the mission statement? Is there
not a mission statement? Hold on. Un America building a movement.
Shut down misinformation with receipts. Use our online content
to combat the red pill pipeline. Spire. How did the red pill
get rolled into all of this stuff? Is this like a way to get
funding? People talk about like the manosphere and red pill cuz
that's what like politicians would understand or like donators.
I don't even know. Taking the fight to the far right. Who is
Okay, so why why this tour? Because nice won't cut it. We're
done asking nicely. It's time to out organize the opposition,
outlast their nonsense, out message their
So, picture Charlie. Who is Turning Point USA? Turning Point
USA is the far-right organization founded and led by ultra manga
extremist Charlie Kirk that brainwashes young people, predominantly
young white men, into an alt-right red pill pipeline.
what is with
the like Marov chain wording of this? Red Pill isn't only dating
stuff, you know? Yeah, but that's not what these people ever
mean. And Charlie Kirk is the furthest thing from any kind of
red pill. Charlie Kirk is the most blue pill keeps yourself plugged
into the machine person that exists on planet Earth. There is
not a single iota of Charlie Kirk's beating being that is red
pill in any way. So you could say, oh well doesn't just mean
doesn't just mean with regards to gender relations. If you're
not using in that context, then no part of Charlie Kirk is outside
of the mainstream, right? No. No part he's like no part of what
Turning Point stands for is outside of the mainstream at this
point. Maybe Charlie Kirk has some opinions that he specified
on certain issues that make him more extreme. I would argue that.
But the Turning Point thing is built to win elections. Get married
young, have kids, support Israel. Yeah, that's really that's
really what it is, isn't it? It's like the most like, hey, you
need to be a a compel. You need to be the perfect cog in the
machine. You need to stay plugged in. Do not wake up. Do not
be disruptive. Do not be you need to be a placid cow for us.
Okay. Turning point USA is like the the goodest goy's perfect
guideline book. Okay. Guide book. The good [__] guide
book. Yes. The GGG. Okay. That's what Turning Point USA is. Turning
point USA is theah Turning Point USA pushes disinformation, attacks
public education, and fuels culture wars to divide, distract,
and destroy. Their real mission to build an army of alt-right
robot voters while training the next generation of right-wing
operative and silence uh right-wing operatives operative and
silence anyone who fights for progress and humanity.
Why are we challenging Turning Point and Charlie Kirk? Because
they're targeting our communities, our campuses, and our future.
Turning Point USA and Charlie Kirk are building a youthpowered
authoritarian movement and they're doing it completely unchallenged
and out in the open. That's why we're showing up. We're not just
responding to their presence. We're organizing to outnumber,
outstrategize, and outlast each and every one of them. Well,
Guys, wait. How What's the quickest way to outlast somebody?
What do they mean outlast? Seems like they've they won. I think
they won. I think it's over, actually. [__] me.
Uh,
why is this important for us to do? We need to build power for
2026 and 2028. 2025 isn't a pause year. It's a staging ground
for our future. The groundwork we lay right now will decide if
democracy lives on in 2026 and beyond. As if uh as a party, if
we want to win elections, protect rights, and protect our country,
we need real deep grassroots infrastructure built by organizers
and influencers alike, not consultants. Okay. Uh the UN America
Tour is how we train, mobilize, and scale that power starting
now. Okay. Okay. Well, they took their homepage down yesterday,
Yaposaurus, which is pretty funny. What did they mean by take
the fight to them? Obviously, they mean like actually trying
to argue with them. Obviously, they do mean uh what do you call
it? Like Charlie Kirk and they they do want to debate Charlie
Kirk. That that was obvious from the beginning. That's why like
Dean and Parker would go get in the lines to talk to Wait, is
this Dean right here? This is Dean, isn't it? I recognize the
back of his head anywhere. This is Dean Withers, isn't it? Am
I wrong? This is Dean. I I recognize that bald spot earlier pick
two. Oh, wait. It actually literally is Dean. Oh, it literally
Oh, it literally is Dean. I'll just be honest. I didn't even
look at the pictures up until this point. I just recognized Dean
by the back of his head.
Uh-oh. Uh-oh. Okay. Are we done with uh we done with Z? We're
not
and to register voters
and to have a dialogue with people that we disagree with in order
to bring people to our side and to win elections. And
Charlie's death has not just made me feel like that can't even
be possible in what's meant to be a free country, but also makes
us scared for our lives.
And if you're one of those people that are laughing about this
and you think that this is funny, I'm just letting you know that
you also have a target on your back too and you're not invincible
either.
And if you want to live in a country where you think it's okay
to just like off your people that you don't agree with politically,
then you should leave this country and you should go live in
a communist country or another country that thinks that that's
okay. What? So I just want to >> How many by the way just
out of like out of interest, how many communist countries are
there? Is it is there like one beyond Venezuela? Is it just Venezuela
and maybe Cuba? Like China cannot actually accurately be like
categorized as a communist country in my opinion at least. I
understand that they still say they're communist, but they're
not a communist country. Yeah. Yeah. China is not a communist
country. That's like state capitalism. China I feel like China
is almost closer to like a fascist country than it is to a Spain
is openly socialist. I don't even know what that means, but it's
not a communist country. North Korea, Cuba, China, Vietnam, and
I don't know what else.
Well, Venezuela, right? Isn't that the whole point? Isn't that
why they're like trying to go to war with Venezuela? >> Pay
my respects to Charlie by saying
that's okay. >> North Korea for sure. >> So, I just
want to pay my respects to Charlie by saying that um what you
built at Turning Point was again impressive and I am so sorry
to the employees at Turning Point and to his family and to his
friends. I again it's like dude I hate to nitpick but how do
you say sorry to the employees before the I it's just weird it's
just weird it's so weird >> and people that loved him and
I very much hope that turning point continues and I very much
hope that we can continue in a safe environment but that seems
to be less and less possible when there are people on both sides
of the aisle that are okay with political
so this is me saying I'm not okay with it.
And again, if you are okay with >> like
to me, this just it's smacks of nothing but hypocrisy
when the person you picked to lead your organization is on the
record as being like totally
thinking it's funny that that firefighter got shot, thinking
that's hilarious,
right?
Like you cannot you cannot masquerade as people who are disgusted
by anyone who would laugh at or be okay with political violence
and then hire that person or or partner with that person to lead
your college campus tour is it's baffling to >> with it
then just like don't engage with me. I want to say thank you
to the people that reached out that were concerned about our
team and our safety and the trauma and um yeah just thank you.
Thank thank you for that support and
we'll keep you updated on next steps and what we will be doing.
>> No, Jayto conservatives laughed about Paul Pelosi and
the hammer guy. That means no one has to has to disavow left-leaning
violence ever. Yeah, I I think probably what Cringle Kesh probably
what your point should be should be something along the lines
of uh yeah that was really bad, really inhuman and I think that's
like awful. I would never want to do that. I would never want
to be that person. Why would you want to be like the people you
hate? The people you think are destroying your country. Why would
that be it? Yeah, we played this yesterday, Riyle, for the same
section. I hate repeating stuff. Uh, let's see here. Okay, we
going to go check out the Staxium stuff. Yeah, we'll check out
the Staxium stuff.
Okay, so you heard Z right at the beginning there say that one
of the people from TPUSA, sorry, one of the people from
America was there. Okay, one of them were there. And this is
the guy. This is the guy who was debating Charlie Kirk. as he
uh apparently as he went down. Let's see him. I >> learn
how to make this video. Um it's been a rough 24 hours. >> Uh
you might recognize this guy. He's been on Destiny's stream before.
He's been on Josiah's stream before. He's done content with a
bunch of people in like the DG kind of sphere. He's done stuff
with Connoy before.
Yeah, I've seen I've seen a lot of people do content with this
guy before. I aware of >> Uh this last person to talk to
Charlie Kirk here's maybe a better vantage point of me. So, I'll
give you some background. I made a video maybe about a week or
two ago, I think. Um, I'll play clips so it's clear about what's
going >> Oh my god. So, Charlie Kirk just said that the
suspected Minneapolis school shooter was trans. First Nashville,
now this. How many times makes a trend? Probably the only way
to do this is to have an ungodly amount of time to parse through
all of the 6,000 mass shootings that have ever happened in the
history of America. I mean, Charlie's counting on the fact that
only a psycho would do all that. Trans people are surprisingly
and extremely nonviolent. Now, while I was scrolling Charlie
Kirk's video, I noticed that he was touring America, and he was
touring universities specifically, and one of these caught my
eye because one of these is the university I'm currently >> uh
can someone find a link to the Cash Patel press conference? Let's
check it out. going to >> obviously that was UVU where
I uh currently go to school and I'm getting a degree in mathematics
and >> ri that exact thing you sent me is on the was on
the website video of what happened mostly because I can barely
watch it. >> It was a while ago though seen it >> but
yeah here's what I asked. I asked you know how many transgender
Americans have been mass shooters the last 10 years. It's too
many. I said the numbers
counting or not counting gang violence. Pop is hurt. Bro, he's
Oh, counting or not counting gang violence. And then he was shot
within seconds. So, this guy was literally looking Charlie Kirk
in the eye as this happened. So, that's incredibly traumatic.
That's really
>> Um,
shout out to CNN for factecking me and saying I'm right.
>> maybe Wendy just tipped twoer 22. Something to note.
Did these guys not learn from the firefighter incident just one
year ago? This edgy proviolence rhetoric doesn't play well. Sad.
>> Um, no. Nobody noticed. Nobody Nobody figured it out.
Um, I'd say that I've seen from what I've seen, conservatives
are the far more violent people this time. Um, I don't know if
it was the same with Trump. I think it was the same with Trump.
Maybe not far more violent. I I've seen a lot of conservatives
doing the whole um like
we're not letting this one go. We're getting revenge this time.
I've seen a lot of that play out. Okay. >> First off, you
sick. >> Oh, sure. Fentes did have the right take. I'm
talking about like a lot of um like individual accounts, the
big influencers, the ones who like I think a lot of people have
had the right take here. And yeah, I highlighted Fuentes's take
as a good one. So >> psychos that think this is the answer,
it's not. I don't know what else to say. It's not. It's awful.
And a father doesn't have his kids anymore.
Charlie had two kids and a Fentes is terrified. It was one of
his followers. Has Fentes ever avowed political violence? I feel
like he's only ever explicitly been against like political violence
on the grounds that it literally doesn't work. Like he's literally
got a Catholic movement that's not about violence at all. I don't
know why people think it would be a groper at all.
Um like that to me is one of the the less likely
people. And I I find it very funny that the um the people who
the people who think it's a groper are also it's like I noticed
Aerodite did this. She was like, "Oh, like it it could just be
a Groper. They hate Charlie Kirk, right?" And I'm like, "Bro,
you're like, "Oh, and they harass Charlie Kirk." And I'm like,
"Dude, you are you're part of UN America. You guys literally
har you do the same harass. You do the same thing. You guys try
to do the same [__] or you're trying, right? I don't
know why you would say that that's like indicative of somebody
who would actually do violence against Charlie Kirk. That's crazy.
Anyway, I think uh I understand that Fuentes didn't get along
with Kirk. I just think like he's they're like an explicitly
like antiviolence movement. They're about like um infiltrating,
right? I think it it would be if it was a grope it be somebody
who's like totally outside of their like mainstream group. Like
you you would you would have to misunderstand what they're about.
Totally. Like they're trying to be like a nefarious
power-driven group who are trying to get deeper into politics
and you would totally misunderstand what they're attempting to
do.
Life and like not to make this about me, but I have two kids
and a wife and if if
my one-year-old boy like his one-year-old boy will grow up without
memories of his dad, it's a tragedy and I don't it's hard to
grapple with. And I'm part of a community that's struggling to
grapple with it right now. And people have obviously pointed
to the irony that I was the point that I was trying to make is
how peaceful the left was right before he got shot. And that
that only makes sense if we stay peaceful.
And as much as I disagree with Charlie Kirk, I'm I'm on the record
for how much I disagree with Charlie Kirk. But like,
man, dude, he
is still a human being. Have we forgotten that? Are we crazy?
Like I stand by so little of everything that he said, but one
of the things that he stood by was
>> It's so weird watching people come out with like every
single person I've seen affiliated with um with with
America said the same thing. I disagree so much with Charlie
Kirk on everything, but the one thing I didn't disagree with
them on was the debate is the foundation of America and we need
to take this debate to college campuses. It's every single one
of them over and over. It's like the exact same dialogue tree,
which is just a little odd to me. It's It's weird for me when
when that [__] goes together. That's not critical
info. Why would you even link that, Porter Bellar? Why would
you even link that? I don't know why you'd even like that. Use
your brain. Um, and I also just
if you ever feel like you want to comment with your little conspiracy
theory on what happened on the event, you are not helping anything.
Actually, I've been talking to the police. We're good. Thank
you. >> And if you're salivating about what happened, don't
I don't know if any of my audience is, but if you are, you're
not part of what I'm trying to build here at all. >> Wow.
It's like word for word. It's bar for bar what uh Z said as well.
Very interesting. What else would they say? Uh I would just expect
it to come in like a different order or whatever. It's like the
exact same things getting said, which is just interesting to
me. um and just discordant with the reality of them having somebody
who headlines their events who has the like an opposing opinion
to it. Right. Right. That's that's what's weird to me. But hey,
maybe that's totally fine with most people. Guys, we're going
to constantly rail on principles we don't have and never actually
like stick to in the real world. Okay. Listen, principles every
every single person who's involved in the America thing, the
like desty political sphere, all have the same thing, right?
where they go listen principles are really important unless I
can maintain a connection by totally like throwing that principle
away unless I can maintain some clout or money by totally throwing
that principle away and then the principle isn't important but
until I am losing money principle sorry until you know I would
be forced to lose money principles are the most important thing
every it's just every single time and it's just goofy I think
I think it's like stupid at this point anyway uh where are we
going from here oh we're going to The Cash Patel press conference.
Let's check it out. Cash Patel 8 minutes. 8 minutes. What? Cash
Patel press conference on Kirk assassination. EI
recctor. Okay, let's change the title up. We need We need a fiveminute
thing. I've got lots of these, don't I? Oh, we can watch the
other Staxiums thing. I don't think so, though. Hold on. Let
me Let me see. I thought I had another fiveminute thing here.
Do I really not? Come on, man. Come on, man. Like right now,
it's in like five minutes. Eight minutes. We need a quick We
need a quick pallet cleanser. Okay. Officials rapid developments
in Charlie Kirk. >> FBI and Utah police postponing a news
conference citing quote rapid developments in our investigation.
End quote. And now a source tells CNN that FBI director Cash
Patel is in route to Utah to assist the investigation.
Hello everyone. I'm >> Hold on. I'm being told to laugh
at JD Vance. Give me a second.
US Vice President JD Vance participated in the honor guard carrying
the casket of Charlie Kirk early at Roland Rightight Air National
Guard Base in Salt Lake City, Utah. Kirk's body accompanied by
his family and for the vice president will now will be flown
to Phoenix, Arizona aboard Air Force 2. I don't know why it's
stilted, guys. J's not helping. I'm sure like you have to understand
these people actually love the country, right? They think JD
Vance is a hero. They probably appreciate GD vents being